qui tend le cramator profite de quelques
moments de répit pour sortir de chez eux
récupérer un peu d'aide alimentaire
depuis quelques jours les affrontements
dans la région se sont calmés mais
personne ici ne se fait d'illusion les
combats vont bientôt reprendre
et de se développer c'était une ville
vivante mais cette guerre elle ne sert à
rien à quoi sert-elle Poutine est devenu
fou je suppose
il y avait 150000 habitants à cramator
ce qu'avant la guerre 75% de la
population a fait la ville d'après les
experts cramatorsk et sloviansk sont les
deux prochaines cibles de l'armée russe
qui grignote du terrain dans cette
région de l'est de l'Ukraine
dans cette tranchée à la frontière du
don-basse les soldats Ukrainiens
attendent la nouvelle offensive rue
s'annoncée par leur état-major confiant
dans l'issue des combats
moins ils attaqueront ils ont des
problèmes avec leurs dépôt de munitions
ils tirent beaucoup moins et dernier
jour sont calmes comparaissent que
c'était avant
par ailleurs les russes continuent de
bombarder le reste de l'Ukraine comme
ici à Nicolaï ou 12 personnes ont été
blessées l'Ukraine qui a annoncé hier
une contre-offensive dans le sud du pays
justement en direction de Kerson dans la
nuit l'armée ukrainienne affirme y avoir
bombardé un dépôt de munition d'après
les forces russes cette frappe aurait
fait cette mort et blessé 60 personnes